I've heard that everyone has an inner
critic
might be a teacher that we had some
a friend
some of the ones called it to me the
inner Hitler
we light up everybody how do you battle
I think it's a good thing it's just some
extent to have an inner critic because I
heard that we are the harshest with
ourselves I don't know if that's true
but I think if you have really high
standards for your work or the way that
you conduct yourself in the world or
whatever it is that that's okay to be to
some extent disciplined and and hard on
yourself
you can go too far maybe but I think
especially in a kind of freelance
profession where no one's telling you if
no one's telling you hey yeah your
screenplay is do or hey you should have
X number of guest stars by now if no
one's saying that to you it's sort of
like you're only holding yourself
accountable to your vision of your best
self I feel like and I think that's all
we can do is be the best version of I I
can just be the best version of me I can
be today and that it's not about
comparing yourself to someone else who
has X number of guest stars or something
whatever it is but
but I think it's okay because that inner
critic keeps you on track to some extent
and and you don't have maybe maybe you
don't have someone else keeping it on
track so you need it how do you handle
comparison in terms of maybe you see
other people in a spot where you'd like
to be and also on the reverse if you can
tell that someone was doing it with you
and making you their sort of higher
power and
the envious or just putting you up on a
pedestal I've always thought that the
only person I want to be envious of is
myself I think that's the goal you know
is to live the life where you know I
wouldn't want anybody else's life
because mine is so awesome but it's
getting there right that that's the
challenge because inevitably someone
else
somewhere that is more successful is on
the a-list is doing X or Y or in this
great movie with this director that you
absolutely love or whatever it is but I
think it goes back to you can only be
the best you you can in any day and you
can only hustle as much as you can
hustle or write as much as you can write
in a day and you have to just be the
best you you can and that's the best
that you can do and it's not about it's
not about what anyone else is doing
they're doing the best they can and yeah
you might have wanted to be in a movie
that they were in okay what are you
going to do about that because you can't
it was already made it's in the past
what are you going to do about it you
know you can reach out to the filmmaker
now and say hey I really like that film
that you made but so-and-so
that I kind of wish I was in that you
don't say out loud but or maybe you do
but you can only work on their food your
projects with them you missed it you
missed the boat last time you know I
think that it's healthy to pay attention
to the world around you and what other
people are doing but try not to let
yourself get nuts about it because that
doesn't I don't know that it helps you I
think it helps you if it motivates you
to change your behavior or to work
harder or smarter or whatever it is
I think that's all you can do is just
accept it Monica
someone once said to me there's apples
and oranges and you
be the best orange you can be you might
not be able to be one of the apples and
for me that was hard to take because I
wanted to be one of the apples yeah so
it sounds like you're just happy being
the best you can be
doing the best of what who you are and
not trying to emulate yourself yeah I
think that's all we can do is I like
that analogy that either you are an
or you're an orange or you're a
lemon or whatever whatever it is that
you're your own unique thing and you
that's the one gift that we have right
as is nobody else can be me and nobody
else can be you and you have to own that
and like really look at what am I really
good at what do I really enjoy doing
what is unique about me as an actor that
even if I'm sitting next to someone
who's way more successful than I am
today that I would beat them for that
part what is that part you know I think
for actors in particular as a writer I'm
always interested in asking people
because I like to write for people
sometimes is what do you do better than
anyone else and a lot of times actors
don't know how to answer that question
and I think every Edition know how to
answer that question is if I put you
next to someone who's like I don't know
someone we've all heard of what would
you beat them at what would you get the
part of that they would not that you
just kind of know you're like yeah they
can't they can't do a better job
someone might cast them but but I know
that I'm I'm better for that part you
know and I think that's that's
interesting that like sometimes people
won't be looking for the orange they'll
be looking for the Apple and you just
have to be ready for that and just be
the best Apple you can be you know I
don't know I think there's something to
be said for what's unique about each one
of us
and if we're not perfect for something
else it's okay we'll be right for all of
those things that are perfect for us
that other people won't have an
opportunity to do
how do we know what our unique gifts
some people are so blind to themselves
that's either in good ways or bad ways
they don't know who their gifts are or
their detriments I think that's a great
question like how do you know what
you're really gonna I think I don't know
I think I think if you don't know your
strengths just speaking as well I think
that applies to actors or writers but
but for actors specifically you know
you've gotten cast in things in the
course of your life and and people maybe
tend to see you a certain way which
either feels comfortable for you or you
feel you know what they're missing
something they're not asking me to do
something that I I know I do really well
and maybe you need to show them that
thing or or write your own scene for
your real that shows that thing that
nobody seems to see you as and maybe
you're right about that maybe you are
really good at it or maybe you do have
some misguidance and maybe you're not as
good which you know you might get some
feedback about like actually know you're
kind of better at this other thing that
everyone has you doing you know but I
guess I think you need to register with
how you feel about the the parts that
you're getting
see if that feels comfortable if that
feels right and if it doesn't maybe
you're better designed to do something
else and that's your strength I think
just experimenting with getting in
people's films and seeing you know does
that doesn't feel right or wrong and and
you'll figure out you figure out what
you do better and what you wind up
meeting 20 other people or hundreds of
other people out for is the stuff that
apparently other people think you do
really well and hopefully you agree but
you do those things really well
you